Yesterday someone asked me,
what do you say to people who are uncomfortable
with women who abort because of a detected disability?
So what? Why does that matter?
What are we going to do with that?
The question reinforces this idea
that there are good girl and bad girl abortions.
That of the thousands of reasons a woman may
decide to terminate her pregnancy,
some are more legitimate or better than others.
And this type of misogynistic reasoning
produces nothing but suffering.
Right now, we have some abortion bans
that have exceptions for good girl abortions.
Like abortions
if the woman's been assaulted.
What does that even mean?
Is it enough to be verbally coerced?
Does there need to be physical violence?
How do you plan on proving that
in a system that doesn't believe women?
But at a fundamental level,
what does it mean to be great? Arguably,
it means to be impregnated without your consent. Right,
but if that's the definition,
aren't abortion bans just societal and cultural? Grape?
Another good girl abortion
is when her life is in danger. Newsflash,
pregnancy is always a danger to your life and health.
Does she have to be hemorrhaging
or at risk of septic shock?
Do they have to try surgery first?
What if your life is at risk because you're suicidal?
Don't worry,
Republicans have actually answered that question.
They have inscribed into law that it doesn't count
under this exception
if the woman is going to kill herself.
As Jessica Valenci explained last week
in front of the Senate,
Republicans did this because they know
that forcing women to be pregnant
will make them want to kill themselves,
and they don't care.
Not to mention
there's rarely one reason women need an abortion.
So what if she needs an abortion because she's broke,
depressed, was coerced,
and the test suggests certain disabilities?
Is that okay with you now?
Demonizing bad girl abortions promotes abortion bans,
which we know does nothing but cause suffering.
Abortion bans increase maternal mortality,
increases infant mortality,
it worsens outcomes for existing children,
makes it less likely that women will have
planned pregnancies later on in her life,
and it makes it less likely that
she will make aspirations for herself
and meet those goals for herself.
And it worsens financial outcomes for families.
Forced birth causes extreme mental anguish and anxiety.
And abortion pans don't even reduce the abortion rate.
Its only goal is to increase the suffering of women
and force them into reproducing for their government
at the risk of their health,
their family,
their finances,
and their dignity. In short,
if there is any abortion that makes you uncomfortable,
I do not care.